this is a glorious day
because
for the first time
since uh she left to go on maternity
leave and give birth to mikey and
charlie
uh her beautiful twin boys
sonum obsession is back in the podcast
studio
you can say something it was good to be
back
yeah you know it was nice uh
it was kind of emotional because
you've you zoomed in once yeah kind of
recently but to have you back here in
the studio and of course i've been uh
here uh
with uh with david david is
sona's assistant and yes you heard that
right my assistant has an assistant
named david hopping
um more he's more your assistant now
well yes but what i'm saying is yeah you
used to have an assistant that's right
it was a great it was a great couple
years which enabled you to do
absolutely nothing
someone was the best boss though yeah it
was yeah so anywho
the best boss yeah because he lets you
watch uh you know big brother or
whatever it is you are anatomy anatomy
okay
whatever yeah i don't know you're so
jealous i haven't watched tv since
mayberry rfd went off the air anyway no
one got that david uh there's two people
out there who got it and boy are they
happy and both of them worked on that
show um listen david has been doing his
best to fill in for you and i think
doing a lovely job doing a fantastic job
here in the podcast studio but great to
have you back sona and people have
missed you people have told me how
everywhere i go people say how sona
doing yeah that's nice yeah can i i i
was really excited to come back
and then i think five minutes into being
here can we tell you what happened yes i
think i want you to say it okay
so i see sona in the parking lot we're
here at the uh earwolf studios
on sunset boulevard
just a fun fact right across the street
from where greg daniels and i got
started in the business in 1985 at
sunset gower studios not necessarily the
news a little fun fact anyway i run into
you in the parking lot as we're both
about to walk up
and we hug
and it's kind of emotional you're back
you look fantastic doesn't she look
fantastic great yeah you look at me
really do you look amazing and we're
just so happy to see you
and then we walk into the offices and
there are a couple of people here and
ruthie's here
uh from team coco and she's happy to see
you and hugs you nice
and uh david's hugging you and
everyone's hugging you
i want to say maybe at most two minutes
went by yeah when
you
found that there's these uh energy bars
here little snack bars yeah and so sona
unwrapped one of the snack bars and was
eating it
and you seemed really happy and
everyone's really happy and you're about
halfway through this bar and i said what
you got there sona you went what is it
what was it it was akashi um chocolate
almond sea salt delicious you know bar
yeah and you were halfway through you're
really enjoying it and i said what is
that and and you went oh it's this and i
said and what flavor is it and you held
it out just a little bit
and
i smacked it out of your hands and it
went flying across the room and
shattered into a million pieces
and you shouted out you dick yes
and
i was thinking
that's what i do minutes
that's what i do
and you think just because you gave
birth to two babies oh my god that you
get to come in here now and be treated
differently and what i'm trying to teach
you is no
i've got to get your reflexes back you
would i mean i've done that on the team
i've done that to you hundreds of times
that's actually featured in a very
popular
youtube video that's out there where i
demonstrate how i do it in front of an
hr person right
no shame you held it out to me because
you completely forgot you were so busy
giving life to the world
that you forgot what it's like to guard
your kashi bar around conan i wasn't
even angry at you i was angry at myself
because i should have seen that coming a
mile away right and i now at this point
like you did that once when we were on
the show where i was holding a plate of
watermelon you're like what do you eat
there i'm like oh it's a plate of
watermelon and you didn't hit it you
kicked it
that was hard
yes and i kicked it perfectly
so it went flying and you know that
takes real coordination it was yeah i
have very long legs and i did a spinning
kick
and hit the plate which was paper
fortunately but i didn't care
it could have been on a ming voz and i
wouldn't have cared and the and the
watermelon went flying crew members were
there
and they were lo and they weren't used
to this
and it's always right when i really want
a snack i find the perfect snack and
it's almost as if something triggers in
your brain where you're like sona's
enjoying herself oh yes let me ruin it
the way a shark can smell blood i can
smell joy
and i have to attack
if i sense joy
i must strike
and you get so happy about your snacks
all i need is food and you take it away
from me yeah exactly oh and you love it
you're so happy oh my god it made me so
happy i'm so glad you're back and i'm so
glad you're snacking and then gullible
enough to when i innocently inquire so
what what flavor is it you hold it out a
little closer to me oh god well it's
actually it's chocolate but it's got a
little fudge swirl and
it goes flying minutes at least your
hair's still up yeah
she hasn't done that yet oh yeah when
you just punch my i have my hair in a
bun and you just punch the bun for no
reason i punch the bun because i think
that doesn't count as actually hitting
you because
it's those are dead cells you never get
my head no i got no that would be abuse
i wouldn't touch the skull or the head
but i figured out a way if i punch
quickly like a little rabbit punch the
bun of your hair it completely falls
apart and you go oh man
it's so good to be back anyway as you
can tell i've missed you oh i've missed
you two